there's a list going around Twitter
today of the top ten most dangerous
celebrities I wonder who could be in
number seven probably should night or
it's your show tonight or should let's
see who it is what it's Chris Hardwick I
don't has nothing to do with me although
I'm very honored I never get put on
lists like this I really feel like I've
made it I don't know if I should be
upset that they called me dangerous or
consider me less dangerous than Carson
Daly who's a very nice guy
but this alarming graphic is actually
McAfee list of the top 10 most dangerous
celebrities searched for online meaning
that cyber criminals use our names to
expose you to malware ironically John
McAfee is not anywhere on this list who
is the most dangerous person in the
world so don't click on anything that
sounds too fake like Chris Hardwick
nip-slip it's a trap I don't have
nipples
boy you have nipples but you don't want
to alright fine fine
and some of that little spend alright
enjoy that accidentally flew abs
comedians what's a computer virus you'd
get from googling one of these
celebrities Dave Foley if you google
Daniel Tosh your computer kicks you in
the balls and thinks it's the funniest
thing that ever happened Suzy Nakamura
if you google Selena Gomez your computer
gets whatever virus justin bieber has
well he's not on the list but if you
google Joel McHale your computer gets so
smug and snarky but it's just so come on